so what would it take to actually build
a Death Star
hey there crazies you may or may not
have seen it before but this is blog
post from 2012 that asked a really fun
question how much would it cost to build
the Death Star they estimated it would
cost about 850 quadrillion US dollars
and would take about eight hundred
thirty thousand years just to produce
the steel well that's boring we can do
better the blog assume the death stars
density would be comparable to an
aircraft carrier which might make sense
if present-day humans were building it
but it was built by a Galactic Empire a
long time ago in a galaxy far far away
how can it be a long time ago if it's
the future it's not the future it's the
past but there are spaceships
oh imagine a group of humans from the
Star Wars galaxy want to live off the
grid they venture out into intergalactic
space in search of a new home finally
they find a remote planet with a
thriving ecosystem and settled down in
an effort to shelter their children from
the woes of Technology they don't pass
on the stories of where they came from
their history is forgotten that planet
they settled on is earth hundreds of
thousands of years ago just go with it
ok so back to the aircraft carrier it's
always look like this where as hallways
on the Death Star
look like this way more room there like
twice as tall and six times as wide huge
the blob chose to use the HMS
Illustrious which has a mass of
twenty-two thousand metric tons and a
volume of about twenty eight thousand
six hundred cubic meters that's over a
thousand school buses worth of space the
Death Star hallways are bigger so it
should be significantly less dense an
average of four times as much radial
space gives us 64 times the volume or 64
times less dense than the illustrious
the first Death Star was a hundred and
twenty kilometers across are you calling
the technical manual again that's not
Canon Star Wars legends is the only
place I can get my data so 120
kilometers across means it has a radius
of 60 kilometers here's a size chart
just so you can get your bearings
that's a volume of 900 trillion cubic
meters multiplying by density we get a
mass of
eleven trillion metric tons or eleven
quadrillion kilograms that's enough to
have a noticeable gravitational pull but
not nearly enough to collapse and form a
solid steel sphere now let's estimate
cost it's really expensive to get things
in a space even with a space elevator so
let's assume the steel was mined and
produced in space from asteroids there's
a lot less gravity and a lot more iron
the average cost of steel on earth in
2016 is about four hundred dollars per
metric ton the steel needed to make a
Death Star would cost 4.4 quadrillion
dollars about 57 times the gross world
product but that's just the earth a
Galactic Empire is going to have a lot
of planets significantly more than 57 so
I think it's safe to assume the wealth
exists in the Empire but how long will
it take in the Star Wars universe they
were beginning construction at the end
of Revenge of the Sith and finished just
before a new hope that's about 19 years
or so they need about 580 billion metric
tons each year just to finish on time
even with production rates like
present-day earth it would only take 350
planet-sized mining operations to
produce the steel totally reasonable for
a galactic empire especially if they
produce faster although it's getting a
little harder to keep this a secret
anyway one last thing to consider the
power source the Death Star is powered
by Kyber crystals you can't being used
for the lightsaber is just way bigger
yes but that needs a dose of science
turning a planet like Earth into an
asteroid field would take a lot of
energy 280 million trillion trillion
joules to be exact it's 57 billion times
the total energy ever used by human
beings or eight and a half times the
total output energy of the Sun every day
for one shot it's no surprise the Death
Star requires 24 hours to recharge I
don't care ok so back to the Kyber
crystals whether they're allowing for a
stable antimatter reaction or collecting
Hawking radiation from evaporating micro
black holes or siphoning matter off the
surface of a very large star like in the
force awakens that fuel will have a
minimum mass of 3 point 1 quadrillion
kilograms because y equals MC squared
that's a little under
third of the mass of the steel needed to
make the death star I think it's safe to
assume the crystals themselves don't
have that much mass the death star was
already hard enough to move around as it
was we don't need to make it more
massive we also know they're not firing
this from a different star system
it could take anywhere from five to a
hundred thousand years to reach its
target so they must be collecting this
mass energy at their destination and
then charging for 24 hours wait a minute
why are we even bothering to move a
whole space station around by calling it
a station they're saying they intend to
keep it stationary besides a moon size
steel ball is going to be difficult to
hide for 24 hours whose idea was this
anyway wouldn't it just be easier to
have the weapons separate from the
station the weapon detaches from the
Death Star goes wherever you need it to
go grabs onto a nice big asteroid takes
24 hours to turn its mass into usable
energy and then fires the weapon can be
small so it's easier to hide and it's a
lot more mobile
at which point why do we even need this
station it's a huge waste of time and
money if all you're trying to do is
build a weapon so do you think the Death
Star was a good idea I'd like to hear
your thoughts in the comments thanks for
liking and sharing this video and until
next time remember it's okay to be a
little crazy